nous nous trouvons sur une base aérienne
principalement utilisés par des
appareils des nations unies et d'ici
quelques minutes
nous allons nous envoler vers une
localité stratégique tenu par les forces
armées centrafricaines c'est parti en
effet la ville de boire et stratégique
dans le sens où elle se trouve sur un
axe routier vital pour l'économie
centrafricaine
cette route relie le cameroun à bangui
et certains axes extrêmement important
pour l'économie et le commerce du pays
car c'est lui qui vient à ravitailler
bangui et le reste du pays
en marchandises et certaines certains
camions sont parfois pris pour cible par
les rebelles comme ici il y a tout juste
quelques jours quand dr tiller parfaite
au sort qui attend par un cadre on est
en effet pour parer aux attaques tous
les jours sont organisés des grands
convois rassemblant des dizaines de
camions qui se retrouve donc sous
escorte jusqu'à la capitale depuis la
frontière avec le cameroun pour aller à
bangui où on appelle ça mc morrow et ça
a été bloqué donc la ville de bangui a
été asphyxié mais avec nos frères russes
tous les jours nous avons un des camions
à bangui le convoi se passe d'une
manière correcte bord de plus de 50
véhicules et c'est encadré le au début
et à la faire ou même mieux on va
trouver des éléments et c'est ça n'a
carrément mixte avec les choix
graphiques est riche en somme et qu'on
voit c'est une diplomate
malgré tout des mouvements de bandes
armées sont régulièrement observés avec
parfois des accrochages sebald il faut
éruption à des moment venu à n'importe
quelle heure sur les axes donc ça
constitue vraiment un danger
dieu merci avec la présence de nos
forces
déficit que la fac à la gendarmerie la
police n'ose aller les russes et autres
on fait que bon il ya quand même le
chemin que vous pouvez voir juste
derrière moi et régulièrement empruntée
par les rebelles et c'est pour cette
raison que les forces centrafricaines
appuyés par leurs alliés russes se sont
installés ici un avant poste pour
contrôler les mouvements de troupes dans
le secteur on est là par rapport à ce
tag cela c'est cet acte-là que les
malfrats utilisent beaucoup et semaine
passée ils ont venu tirer sur l'auto
base nous allons tirer des parle
dérogatoire de base et on a riposté et
l'oncle fuite
on l'aura compris cet axe de
communication est vital pour l'économie
du pays
c'est véritablement un combat quotidien
pour les forces centrafricaines épaulé
par les instructeurs russes que de
rendre cette